these are US Airforce stealth fighters
preparing for takeoff in South Korea on
a deadly serious training mission this
morning six of those f-22 Raptors are
taking part in a large joint air drill
with South Korea the show of force
follows North Korea's test of its most
powerful intercontinental ballistic
missile the north korean newspaper
called the joint exercise on all-out
provocation Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham told Face the Nation the Pentagon
should take US military families out of
harm's way it's crazy to send spouses
and children to South Korea given the
provocation of North Korea so I want
them to stop sending dependents and I
think it's now time to start moving
American dependents out of South Korea
Ben Tracy flew with an Air Force
squadron participating in the training
he's in Tokyo this morning Ben good
morning good morning the military
exercise is now underway involved 230
aircraft in 10,000 US military personnel
we went to the US Air Base in Misawa
Japan and flew with the 35th Fighter
Wing to see how they're preparing for
the increasing threat from North Korea
I flew in the back seat of Maj Richards
meetings f-16 fighter jet he goes by the
call-sign punch
seconds into our flight he punches our
plane straight up in the air we climbed
thirteen thousand feet at nearly 500
miles per hour that's one way to take
off soon we are soaring right up the
face of a massive snow-capped Mountain
and it's later just barely above the
surface of a lake but this is not a
joyride for pilots leg punch this is a
serious training mission flying low
through the canyons of a Japanese
mountain range helps him prepare for
actual combat conditions in which he
would try to avoid detection
there are 44 f-16 to the Misawa Air Base
and in a war with North Korea they would
likely be the first plane sent in to
take out enemy radar at North Korea's
air defenses if needed and if called on
we're ready and we're ready to go right
now
100% Colonel Scott Jobe is commander of
the 35th Fighter Wing he says repeated
missile launches by North Korea have led
the Air Force to increase the number but
also the complexity of their training
exercises to make sure that we're ready
and prepared to respond to any sort of
additional testing that the Kim regime
does that readiness means pilots like
punch are spending a lot of time on the
ground making sure their f-16s are ready
for action and once in the air that he's
prepared for any mission he may be given
or flying today our latest recognition
in this scenario our plane flies low
over the water until he spots the target
ahead we then pop up in the air and
simulate dropping a bomb on an enemy
port where weapons or cargo may be
located everyone we talked to on the
base that they hope diplomacy works and
it doesn't come to an actual military
conflict with North Korea but they say
if it does they are ready as punch
confidently told me while we are flying
in terms of North Korea we can handle
that problem Nora I have no doubt that
cannon Ben Tracy nice flying up there
great job appreciate it